But that's it,
they found it!
At last!
And yes,
rebirth to 1 head of list for the European.
So it's about time,
right,
because it was starting to show.
It's still quite curious,
this party that is supposed to embody faith in Europe,
which is the most European party
and who finds no one to go to school in Europe.
So they found Valerie Ayer.
Valérie Ayer who is a Member of Parliament
already in Europe,
who is the owner of the renaissance group
in the European Parliament
and sticks to it because nobody wants to stick to it.
So obviously,
his colleagues
explain how competent it is,
how much it is
extraordinarily
both of
technical and at the same time a field woman.
In addition she is the daughter and granddaughter of a farmer
thought.
So right now,
it's great.
In short,
1 real one.
Well,
it is true that last time already,
Emmanuel Macron's party had really,
really rowed to find someone.
By the way,
the proof is that they had ended up putting
Nathalie the Elder.
Well,
let's hope Valerie elsewhere
will not be of the same level.
The blunders that had
chained Nathalie the Elder remained in the
anal.
The problem is that
precisely,
Emmanuel Macron launched the of the European elections,
notably at the agriculture show.
Since
obviously,
to get out of the agricultural crisis,
the only thing he found,
well,
it was to explain that all this
came from the Rassemblement National.
Yes,
because when it's not the Russians,
is.
The National Rally,
it is the same thing.
And finally,
the only program
of rebirth
for the European elections,
it seems to be to denounce the National Rally.
It is nevertheless a short project for Europe.
Because obviously,
we can draw up the assessment of Jordan Bardella
or European Parliament,
it will be done very very quickly.
By the way,
we can also put the National Rally
in the face of its contradictions,
then, for the blow,
there will be work to do.
But for all that,
to be satisfied
to erect the Rassemblement National as a repulsor
as in every election,
will not be enough to galvanize crazy people.
But in 1 sense,
it doesn't seem very serious.
We understand very well
that the Macronists have 1 calculation in mind,
the French do not care about the European elections,
says the party that is supposed to make us love Europe.
And so it's useless to try to fight
to bring in the abstentionists.
What counts,
is to mobilize your camp.
And to mobilize your camp,
what do we do?
Well,
we stir up the danger,
ed by fear.
The fear of the National Rally,
the fear of Russia,
both at the same time.
And this is 1 permanent message
addressed in fact
to the Macronist defenders so that they move
for the European elections.
So finally,
Valerie Ayer or 1 other,
It doesn't really change anything.
The problem is that the European elections,
in fact,
it's 1 issue,
there are things to decide,
there are elements that will be crucial
in the years to come,
even if only the enlargement projects and especially the
the question of vote amplification
by a qualified majority.
We will have to position ourselves on this.
So take it over the handle,
thinking that it will go well
if we can't go too far behind.
The National Rally,
it is nevertheless largely under the hand,
it's too good.